silent and empty
this is mikalayevka
it's like this across many towns and
villages in the east of ukraine
russia says it wants to take the dunbas
region
most people here have fled fearing the
russian advance
those who remain wait for whatever
supplies they can get
they are giving humanitarian aid i don't
know what it is exactly but everyone
else is here so i'm here inside
volunteers pack food for those in need
umar is helping distribute the bags of
chicken and canned food
have you seen what's going on outside
they're firing have you filmed anything
out there have you seen the strikes it's
every day it's very hard the elderly are
struggling while the children are
playing now it's hard let's see what
happens in the future
the local council would usually cut the
grass here
now it's left for the goats
a rare sight of a child playing
the occasional sound of rocket and
artillery fire in the distance
they don't even flinch here anymore
mikolayevka is around 12 kilometers away
from where russian troops are there used
to be 15 000 people living here but many
have left but amongst those that still
remain opinions are divided
i think ukraine should be an independent
country but without foreign influence to
be without uncle sam i think we don't
need them ukraine was a very rich
country look what they have done the us
are not good i don't think they have
ever done anything good for us or that
they ever will
russian-backed forces took this town
back in 2014
only to be pushed out by the ukrainian
military
i don't hope for anything good i don't
care anymore at my age i'm worrying
about young people the small children
they haven't even had the chance to live
we have our families people we love
why are they bombing why are they
killing children
the military told us we're not allowed
to film places that have been struck in
this town it is in the path of the
russian advance and many here believe
it's only a matter of time before
russian forces try and take it asad beg
al-jazeera mikhail